it seems like twitch is starting to lose
some of its biggest creators most
recently lily pichu and myth both
announced they were signing to youtube
gaming taking with them their 2.5 and
7.4 million fans respectively
good decision decisions have made me who
i am
and this
is my decision but it didn't just start
here these are just the latest in a long
line of creators that have made the
switch in the last year or so cycuno
ludwig one of brazil's biggest content
creators no brew hell they even got tin
the tatman now it's time for the next
big thing in my career i'll be streaming
now exclusively on youtube gaming twitch
is still a giant with thousands of huge
streamers but with this many big names
making the switch who knows what the
world of streaming will look like in the
future twitch is here they are the top
dog they have market share they have the
best product site in terms of what they
have for live streaming but youtube is
they're getting there